start with any four digit number that  has at least two different digits say  1482 form the largest and the smallest  numbers using these digits and subtract  the smallest one from the largest one  this subtraction gives us  7170  take the answer and repeat the process  we get 7731-1377  we get  6354 we continue the process and the  last number we get will always be 6174  no matter which four digit number we  take with at least two different digits  and if we try this again with 6174  we will again get  one hundred and seventy four two more  things to know here the maximum number  of iterations required will be seven and  this works for all numbers between zero  and nine thousand nine hundred and  ninety nine if it's a two digit number  we just have to add two zeros to the  left  [Music]